[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here in the united
states we've been so deeply engrossed in
our own debates over whether men should
be allowed to compete on girls swim
teams or whether it's immoral to carry
our groceries in plastic bags that we
have missed the fact that the government
of china has been busy with its own
agenda taking over the world
in the space of just 15 years for
example the chinese have succeeded in
recolonizing the entire continent of
africa didn't think that could happen
well it is happening in africa china now
calls the shots and takes the natural
resources for itself
period
as of tonight there is only one
remaining african country that dares to
recognize taiwan and it happens to be
among the smallest countries in africa
swaziland
everyone else on the continent obeys
beijing
but wait a second how can this be
happening
isn't colonialism racist and bad
yes it is and no one's worse and more
racist than the chinese go on chinese
social media sometime and see how they
describe the africans they've subjugated
it's horrifying
so why isn't the new york times writing
stories about any of this
you know why because the new york times
is on china's side that's why they all
but ignore the brutal chinese
colonization of latin america which is
also in full swing right now
colonialism violates everything the new
york times once claimed to believe in
but that's okay because they never
really believed any of it anyway it was
always about power
we came to brazil this week to see for
ourselves what the chinese are doing to
latin america we're making a documentary
about it for our tucker carlson original
series
brazil has the last pro-american
government in latin america it's our
single most important ally in the
western hemisphere
allowing brazil to become a colony of
china would be a significant blow to us
and potentially a very serious military
threat the bide administration appears
to be in favor of it
one person is emphatically not in favor
of it is the president of brazil jair
borsen bolsonaro so of course the
american media hate him here's some of
their slander
the united states isn't the only country
lurching dangerously towards
authoritarianism it is happening all
over indeed just yesterday for example
brazilians elected jair bolsonaro
usually you don't get rid of an aspiring
dictator through the electoral process
brazil is going to have trouble with
bolsonaro it's that same
authoritarian
like
women hating
you know racist energy he's the trumper
brazil president bolsonaro doesn't
believe in social distancing doesn't
want lockdowns much much more extreme
than president trump brazil's far-right
nationalist president jair bolsonaro
spoke at an event in dallas these two
men and fellow travelers like donald
trump and vladimir putin represent the
growing global threat to the ideas of
liberalism
these are people whose research consists
of three minutes on wikipedia on the way
to the studio he's a racist of course he
is he quote doesn't want lockdowns
there's your proof
but it is the last clip from plagiarist
fareed zakaria that explains why they're
so mad at bolsonaro
bolsonaro fried zakaria tells us
represents a quote growing global threat
to the ideas of liberalism liberalism
meaning
neo-liberalism meaning globalism and in
fact that is true bolster is no justin
trudeau he's not a low iq fascist who'd
be working as an instagram influencer if
he doesn't have his own army he's not
the president of ukraine who shuts down
television stations that dare to
criticize him and outlaws opposition
parties and arms nazis
in conventional terms bolsonaro is in
fact liberal he has done nothing to stop
civil liberties in brazil but at the
same time he is a nationalist he cares
about his country he resists china
therefore he must be stopped george
soros hates him and so does joe biden
he's not with the program
so naturally we wanted to meet him
yesterday we did we sat with bolsonaro
for more than an hour
and the first thing we learned is that
the left in brazil hates him very much
they tried to kill him when he first ran
for president four years ago with very
little money in the backing of no party
he came out of nowhere to get 57 million
votes but he almost didn't survive to be
elected he was stabbed by a leftist
almost to death at a rally
at which point the left funded lawyers
to come in and rescue his attempted
murderer
an amazing story that hasn't gotten a
ton of coverage in the united states
he's an authoritarian says msnbc all
right
so we asked bolsonaro about the stabbing
in our conversation we also asked him
about his christian faith which is on
display something else that triggers
them we asked him about our supreme
court's stance on abortion his views on
gun rights
and we asked him fundamentally why do
you think you're so hated
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight